last night's cacophonous and chaotic
Republican presidential primary debate
ended with one of the wildest questions
ever posed in any presidential debate
none of you have indicated that you're
dropping out so
which one of you on stage tonight should
be voted off the island
please use your marker to write your
choice on the notepad in front of you 15
seconds starting now of the people on
the stage who should be I'm absolutely
serious with all due respect I mean
we're here like we're happy to debate I
think that that's disrespectful to my
fellow competitors
let's talk about the future of the
country
[Applause]
there's a good answer from DeSantis that
was the smart way to play it what's
funny is Christy then went along and he
said yeah we don't want to participate
but he was the first one when she said
it he just starts writing down on his
board but okay then they said no we
don't want to participate at all it's a
terrible terrible question and everyone
now is attacking Dana Perino for that
game show question I however thought the
question was basically appropriate it's
not appropriate for a presidential
debate but it is appropriate for
whatever last night was
because last night was not a
presidential primary debate because
nobody on that stage is likely to be the
Republican nominee for president
the front runner the Far and Away front
runner the front runner by 40 maybe 50
points
was absent and so the entire debate was
a little bit more than a mildly
entertaining sideshow
I'm Michael knowlesis the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show AOC is fired up
I'm here in our nation's capital I spent
some time with some members of Congress
yesterday and one of those members of
Congress was not Alexandria
ocasio-cortez she was too busy being
fired up on immigration we'll get to
that in one second first though I'm
going to give you
the entire summary of what has been
called a debate by some people in about
60 seconds I was on Tim Poole's show
last night we actually all had forgotten
that the debate was even on so when I
get there he said hey man we gotta
change the order of this show because we
gotta we gotta react to the debate I
guess so we watched it together and I
did find it mildly entertaining and I
did find some of the answers pretty good
I thought DeSantis did very very well
DeSantis was the winner of the debate he
did better than he did at the first
debate uh it was it was good the vague
was the most Under Fire everybody was
attacking Vivek he did very very well
not unexpectedly you know he's a sharp
guy he's he's able to think and speak
very clearly but he was extremely uh
under attack last night and he did he
did pretty well uh Nikki Haley I felt
hurt herself she started out the debate
pretty strong and then she became angry
she she seemed angry and even somewhat
insulting later on into the debate so I
think she sort of hurt herself in fact
one of the defining features of the
debate was Nikki and Vivek just
attacking each other this is infuriating
because Tick Tock is one of the most
dangerous social media apps that we
could have and what you've got I
honestly every time I hear you I feel a
little bit Dumber for what you say
because I can't believe you know they
hear me Tick Tock situation what they're
doing is these 150 million people are on
Tick Tock that means they can get your
contacts they can get your financial
information they can get your emails
they can let me just say text messages
in China not America excuse now wanting
kids to go and get on the social media
that's dangerous for all of us you when
you were in business with the Chinese
that gave Hunter Biden five million
dollars we can't trust you we can't
trust you have tick tock
that was pretty much it that was
basically the whole debate and I think
Nikki believed that she looked good at
the last debate when she went after
Vivek that was her best part of the last
debate performance this I felt was too
much though and it was cacophonous and
some of the attacks there she seemed to
suggest that
Vivek was involved in paying off Hunter
Biden or something I don't think that's
the point she meant to make but that's
kind of what it sounded like and it just
didn't didn't look good for either of
them but it really didn't look good for
Nikki uh but other candidates were
interrupting too Tim Scott
interrupted throughout basically the
entire debate anytime any anyone was
asked a question on that stage Tim Scott
would would try to respond so much so
that they they cut his microphone and
you could only hear Tim on everyone
else's microphone through the ambient
noise these are good people who are
tainted by a broken system and it's not
the fall
thank you for speaking while I'm
interrupting you said
you can't be on both sides gentlemen
you'll have your turn one of the
challenges
in China everybody knows that if I may
if I may address
I learned so much you know that really
showed me a new side of all of the
candidates I think that's really going
to affect my vote don't you no no that
was it and uh uh Tim Scott was
frustrated because he felt he wasn't
getting enough questions but Tim Scott's
not polling very high so when he kept
trying to when he kept trying to
interject it just seemed desperate and
and the debate seemed desperate for
basically everybody and the reason for
that is because the guy who has had the
commanding lead for the entirety of the
primary going back 14 months now didn't
even bother to show up that's how income
sequential he felt the debate to be and
some voters especially if you don't like
Trump might say well that was wrong of
him not to show up and he owes us the
respect of showing up but
if you believe any of the polls
certainly if you believe all of the
polls taken together which haven't
really changed very much Trump didn't
have to do that and nothing has moved
the needle and I'm skeptical that
anything is going to move the needle now
the one answer of the night that I felt
did land a real blow on Trump was given
by Ron DeSantis and it was in response
to Trump's attacks on Ron desantis's
pro-life policies
how are you going to win over
independent pro-choice voters in Arizona
same way we did in Florida we won the
greatest Republican victory in a
governor's race and the history of the
state over 1.5 million votes we were
winning places like Miami-Dade County
Palm Beach that nobody thought was
possible because we were leading with
purpose and conviction I reject this
idea that pro-lifers are to blame for
midterm defeats I think there's other
reasons for that the former president
um you know he's missing in action
tonight he's had a lot to say about that
he should be here explaining his
comments to try to say that pro-life
protections are somehow a terrible thing
I want him to look into the eyes and
tell people who've been fighting this
fight for a long time we're better off
when everybody counts and I think we
should stand for what we believe in I
think we should hold the Democrats
accountable for their extremism
supporting abortion all the way up until
the moment of birth that is in fantaside
and that is wrong
this was basically a Flawless answer and
it was a Flawless answer because he
rejected the premise of the question the
premise being that pro-life policies and
pro-life advocacy turn off moderate
Centrist
liberal voters and he says I don't think
that's true I think that we persuade
people when we lead with courage and
conviction so actually if if you've got
a pro-life policy that is consistent and
coherent and you can explain your
reasoning for it that's going to
persuade more people than some middle of
the ground literally split the baby kind
of policy where you say okay we're going
to kill babies who are this old but
we're not going to kill babies who are
that old uh so I thought that was good
and then he pivoted off a bit and then
he got his attack on Trump in which is
the point of these debates is to
articulate your view and be persuasive
and then attack your opponents I thought
he did that pretty effectively and then
he pivoted it to Democrat extremism so
he didn't just leave himself at the very
early part of the abortion debate which
is harder to win he he brought it all to
the end and he said these Democrats want
to kill babies at the moment of birth or
later and that that's completely insane
and that's out of step with voters and
so we're going to keep articulating
pro-life uh it was good really good
answer
even that answer I don't think moves the
needle and the reason is because Trump
has already served as president
this is why
Trump sees no need to go to the debate I
think he has no need to go to the debate
this is why his poll numbers don't
really seem to move after the debates
because Trump has a track record so what
Trump can do is if people don't like
what he said about pro-life and don't
like him attacking Ron desantis's
pro-life policies even if he was
probably only doing that because he's
attacking everything about Ron DeSantis
and sometimes because DeSantis can sound
to the right of him on certain issues
he's going to attack him Trump is going
to attack DeSantis from the left and
that's going to irritate conservatives
but even then Trump can just point to
his record and say I got Roe v Wade
overruled
and that is going to be persuasive for
most people I think
and my proof of that is
his polls haven't moved
according to any of them and now I know
some people are saying well Michael did
you believe the polls in 2016 when it
showed Hillary Clinton was leading Trump
when it showed that Hillary had a 99
chance of winning the election and
we have to we have to remember what
actually happened in 2016. the polls
showed Hillary was consistently up over
Trump but that 99 number was a
meta-analysis of some Wong sitting in an
ivory Tower somewhere saying well given
all of the data here I just think the
likelihood that Hillary wins not the
percentage of people who are going to
vote for but the likelihood that Hillary
wins is 95 97 99 uh and then Trump uh
performed the polls and Hillary
underperformed
but we're talking about in this case
literally every poll that shows Trump up
at least 20 points
and every poll in all these Battleground
states where Trump has a significant
advantage
so so the conspiracy the pro-trump
conspiracy among pollsters and political
scientists would have to be so
pronounced that they've created a 30 or
40 or more than 40 Point Mirage of
of support for Donald Trump what is more
likely that
or that Trump has many of the advantages
of an incumbent because he's running
sort of practically as an incumbent I
think probably the latter the the most
surprising candidate I think the one
candidate who might actually really have
helped himself in the debate last night
was North Dakota governor
Doug burgum I think that the liberal
left is seems to be just completely bent
on Prosecuting law-abiding citizens that
are gun owners because every solution
they have to this is take away the
Second Amendment rights of Americans and
somehow that's going to solve the
problem but all these cities was that
we're talking about that showed the
videos of tonight they have some of the
strictest gun laws in the country so we
know that that's not what's working but
we have to do is get back to the core
issues about the family we have to get
back to behavioral health and mental
health we've got to get back to actually
enforcing the laws these people talked
about and like we've done in North
Dakota where we're we've got the goal
and we're on the track to being the most
military friendly state in the nation
we've got the most military and the most
support of what we're doing in terms of
law enforcement because the the morale
is down because we've been defunding the
police because they've been attacked in
the press the police have become the bad
guys when they're the one they there's
all these jobs available in America why
would you be a policeman if people only
respect them every time I see a
policeman the first thing I say is thank
you and so does everybody else in my
family and most of the people in our
state because they know we have to
respect the people that are out there
defending us every single day
Doug burgum are you feeling the bergam
meant to Burger momentum bergamentum are
you feeling it are you a burger maniac
uh burgum probably not not going to be
the nominee burgum is pretty liberal on
the social issues but his numbers might
improve because I think he's somewhere
around one percent so he might double or
triple or quadruple he actually did
pretty well introducing himself to the
people last night so how did it end it
ended with the vague being bold and
taking bold stances he came out against
Birthright citizenship I thought that
was very cool I he
Vivek takes a lot of old stances and
he's he's pursuing something similar to
the Trump path in 2016. in terms of ways
to stand out maybe it will benefit him
he was so severely attacked last night
at the debate I'm not I'm not sure which
way it goes or if his numbers move at
all DeSantis he he did a great job doing
the DeSantis performance which is to
seem very disciplined very competent
have a clear political vision and just
not be that sexy you know being being
Trump with perhaps more discipline and
less sexiness which to some people
sounds great but to a lot of people it
doesn't doesn't do very much Nikki I
think probably hurt herself Tim I think
probably hurt herself a little bit was
there anyone else on stage oh Chris
Chris Christie Chris Christie was not
did not have a good performance did not
look good try to fuse zingers out at
Trump didn't they didn't quite land so
where does that leave us
in basically the exact same place that
we were before the debate
happened okay
these candidates the ones who are not
polling very well need an off ramp and I
would encourage you also to check out
ramp right now head on over to ramp.com
Knowles are you looking for a better way
to simplify your business finances
across expenses vendor payments and
accounting if so ramp could be a
complete game changer for your business
ramp is a corporate card an expense
management software designed to help you
save time and money with ramp you can
issue cards to every employee with
limits and restrictions and automate
expense reporting so you can stop
wasting time at the end of every month
ramps accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to the time that you will save each
month on employee expenses will allow
you to close your books eight times
faster businesses that use ramp save an
average of 3.5 percent within the first
year ramp is easy to use get started in
less than 15 minutes whether you have
five employees or five thousand
right now get
250 dollars when you join ramp just go
to ramp.com
that is r a m p.com slash Knowles cards
issued by Sutton Bank and Celtic Bank
members FDIC terms and conditions apply
now there's another debate that's going
to take place not with the primary
contestants yet that that one will be in
a little bit the next debate coming up
is going to be between the California
governor Patrick Bateman
doing business as Gavin Newsom and
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis and
Newsome is already trash talking
DeSantis a month out from the debate why
are you doing that and what is your
strategy well it's I don't know if
that's the right question why is he
doing it is the right question he's
running I think I'm not sure after
tonight but currently he's running for
president United States uh do you think
he's still going to be you think he'll
still be a candidate November 30th
that's an open-ended question part of me
wonders if you know the fact that he
took this debate the fact that he took
the bait in relation to this debate
shows that he's completely unqualified
to be president United States that's my
humble first why is that you're baiting
him with the debate offer I mean why is
he debating a guy he's not even running
for president when he's running for
president he's showing up at the Reagan
Library hollowed groud and he puts out
an ad today not first presidential
campaign to promote a debate against the
governor of California I mean this guy's
distracted so I don't know that he has
it in his heart I think here's my
personal opinion about Ron Santos he
regrets running for president he made a
huge mistake
so he keeps going on like this just
taunting DeSantis and
it reminds me of a WWE match
or even in an actual sport that isn't
just show business like a boxing match
when they're when they're trash talking
before boxing you know this guy I'm
gonna wipe the floor with in this case a
complete joke he you know my I think he
regrets running he's a he's unfocused
he's undisciplined he's just mocking him
relentlessly uh this too
is a sideshow I mean that unfortunately
that's the point that Gavin Newsom is
right about is that this debate probably
will not determine
the 2024 presidential race the thing
that he's being dishonest about here is
that he's not running for president
Gavin Newsom is obviously trying to run
for president he's not willing to put
himself up against Joe Biden because he
thinks that then Biden would grind him
up in the way that Donald Trump is
attacking Ron DeSantis right now but he
obviously wants to run for president and
this DeSantis versus Newsom debate is
the undercard debate if Joe Biden's
Marionette strings collapse and you know
he falls to the ground or if Donald
Trump is sent to Elba or Saint Helena
and and uh or or he's you know taken out
with the Hillary special then there will
be an opening and and Santa's perhaps
can fill that Gap but as of now even
that and I think that could be a
substantive debate about two different
Visions for America you want America to
be like California do you want America
to be like Florida which way are the
U-Haul trucks moving I think it could be
a great substantive debate but once
again don't shoot the messenger here
folks I'm just the one who
has to see things clearly past the event
through to the election I don't see
how this moves
the needle now speaking of Republicans
engaging with corrupt Democrat
politicians
Bob Menendez
still under Fire
a lot of people calling on him to resign
but oddly enough
not very many Republicans calling on
Menendez to design and to resign rather
and mediaite has this headline mediaite
says why are no Senate Republicans
calling for Menendez to resign
Senate Republicans Democrats have all
attacked him call called on him to step
down but the Republicans won't do it
what's that about why won't they do it
two reasons one
because the doj is corrupt
and the corrupt doj has been weaponized
against Republicans in recent years so
we are just generally more willing to
give the accused the benefit of the
doubt than Democrats are when it comes
to the doj but that said Menendez is
obviously corrupt and we've all known it
for a decade so
why why won't the Republicans call on
him to resign the simple answer is
because the longer this drags out the
longer Menendez holds onto that seat the
better chance a republican has of
replacing Menendez once the seat
eventually and inevitably opens up
so Menendez is holding on because he
wants to get a sweetheart deal so he
doesn't spend the rest of his life in
prison
Democrats are clamoring for him to
resign because they don't want this
continued Scandal and they don't want to
lose the seat and Republicans we're just
going to sit back and watch the show I
guess that's that's the moment of
politics that we're in right now is just
sort of sitting back and watching the
show because there's not very much that
we can do to alter the course of events
in politics I don't think there's very
much that we can do in the 2024
presidential primary I think it just is
what it is and it has been for 14 months
and I don't think there's much we can do
with Menendez he's going to resign her
he's not going to resign but if we if we
at least don't push him to resign then
this Scandal is going to drag on and
Republicans can win in New Jersey we
have one in New Jersey even Chris
Christie managed to get himself elected
and we might be looking at a Republican
senator so keep it up
Mr Menendez we you are innocent until
proven guilty
now
the the political health of our country
not so great uh when you're thinking of
your own personal health you might want
to go check out
Medishare right now go to medishare.com
Michael as a daily wire listener you are
not only informed you're handsome and
pretty you're also engaged and value
your freedom and responsibility that is
why we think that you will like
Medishare Medishare is a community-based
approach to health care that lines up
with the principles you believe in your
values matter and with Medishare your
health care dollars won't be used for
medical procedures that don't line up
with your beliefs Medishare is the
highest rated Healthcare sharing
Ministry with a 30-year proven track
record it's not health insurance it's a
community of 400 000 Believers committed
to caring and sharing with one another
members save up to fifty percent five
zero percent or more on their monthly
health care costs for a limited time
daily wire listeners will receive a 150
gift card when you join Medishare to
find out more go to medishare.com
Michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l that is metashare.com
m-i-c-h-a-e-l terms and conditions
Supply make sure you head on over right
now so a daily wire listener will
receive save 150 dollars in a gift card
medishare.com
Michael
I tell you all the time
I'll say it again even though I hate to
say it and it pains me
but don't say I didn't tell you so the
yes or no game has sold out over at
dailywire.com shop again you know what
it will come back in stock but you need
to secure your game if you have not
already if you already have the classic
game be sure to get the all-new
conspiracy theory expansion pack in time
for the spooky season and speaking of my
collection and the rapidly approaching
change of season if you are even mildly
familiar with this show you're probably
aware of my autumnal affinity for a
certain seasonal beverage I am in fact
the PSL King of the daily wire the
pumpkin spice latte so what better way
to bring the fall atmosphere into your
home than with the all-new Michael
Knowles pumpkin spice candle the pumpkin
spicele Knolls candle available now in
my collection I think that one sold out
too but we've managed to get more in
stock don't wait order your candles and
your yes or no game now dailywire.com
shop
speaking of Hispanic Democrats
AOC
has a brutal accusation for republicans
which is that we run our mouths about
the immigration problem all the time
but we don't have any solutions
I didn't hear in your testimony the
alternative sites you've advocated for
could you remind me of which those are
well
in the conversation as we know as we I'm
sorry I only have 18 seconds which are
the sites that you propose as an
alternative
I don't have a proposal so you don't
have a proposal alternative
no proposed alternative
no Solutions here no ideas here but
Democrats we're authorizing 500 000 work
permits so people can get on their feet
and support themselves Democrats were
proposing comprehensive immigration
reform Democrats were talking about
saying let's reassess our foreign
policies so that people aren't fleeing
you know making sure that we aren't
participating in the destabilization of
what's Happening abroad and all I'm
hearing right now is that we're not
being met in the middle no support no
path to citizenship no identified
Alternatives just grievances we need to
get it together
and make sure that we're getting on the
right page and if the ideas being
presented here in this community are
being disagreed with I'd like to see
some actual functional Alternatives that
Center and preserve the Dignity of both
people who are coming here to fulfill an
American Dream and the American citizens
here who want to support them
that was a whole lot of words
without any particular solutions that I
heard from AOC either so this is her
clip AOC she's taken a page out of the
daily wire facts and logic Clips where
she's got the the Fast Cuts and it goes
on to the speaker and onto the
questioner and then she gets the nice
60-second Zinger out there pioneered by
Young America's foundation and other
right-wing groups and she's flipping and
she said you have no Solutions you have
no Solutions and then she babbles and
blathers for 60 seconds
without offering any solutions herself
the accusation isn't even legitimate
Republicans have very clear Solutions
here is my solution I got two of them
for immigration
we should restrict immigration
and we should expand deportations
I solved it do I get a prize from AOC I
did it
we should restrict it
we should restrict all immigration
obviously
illegal immigration but also legal
immigration because we have way too many
people coming into the country and it's
no knock on the people but the movement
of foreigners into the United States
over the last 65 years is the largest
movement of human beings ever in
recorded history and it's led to social
breakdown because there's there's no
longer a coherent cohesive Society so we
got to slow that down drastically I'm
not saying we totally seal up the border
and don't let a single human being in
I don't think that's practicable I don't
think but we could drastically reduce
all immigration illegal and legal
immigration
and we could do it pretty easily we've
done it before in American history and
then what about deportations am I saying
we're going to deport every single
illegal that's in the United States no I
don't think it's practical I don't think
most people would want it it's not going
to happen
but we could drastically expand
deportations you've got criminals now
who who go around who kill people who
sell drugs who who sell flesh or pimps
who are working for the cartels and then
they get arrested and they get let off
the hook
so we could just
reduce the threshold for which someone
is deported drastically that would
drastically increase the deportations
while not going after you know the the
really sweet innocent little person
who's just following uh his or her
lights who doesn't commit all that many
crimes other than the crime of entering
the country illegally and the kind of
person who most Americans don't want to
see deported okay they're going to be at
the bottom of the deportation list so
it's probably not going to happen
but why can't we do that why can't we
just directionally enforce laws that are
already on the books and drastically
restrict immigration and drastically
expand deportation that seems simple
that's my solution
yet they won't do it the Democrat AOC is
not going to do that she wants to open
the Border completely and flood the
country with foreigners but the
Republicans don't want to do it either
the Chamber of Commerce Republicans
don't want to do it don't tell me we
don't have Solutions I got a simple
solution we've used it many times in
American history and it worked out great
and now that we're not following my
solution things are not working out so
great now speaking of transporting
people Transportation secretary Pete
bootage he decided to do his job for a
little bit he took a break from the the
breastfeeding and the paternity leave
and Mr Buddha judge
is gone on TV to say that we have got to
shift to electric cars because the
electric cars are coming
it's going to happen whether you want it
or not whether we do anything or not
cars are going to become electric so get
on board
that concern in terms of the transition
and who would suffer during that
transition uh what's your response to
that
well it's absolutely right look I come
from South Bend Indiana it's the home of
UAW Local five and UAW Local nine I saw
how the past generation of Union auto
jobs helped build the middle class and
build communities like the one that I
grew up in I also saw what happened when
uh when those factories closed what the
UAW is trying to do right now is to make
sure that this next chapter of the Auto
industry which let's be very clear these
cars are going electric with or without
us look they're going electric and so
the the union workers who are protesting
because all these mandates mostly
climate change BS mandates from the
Biden Administration to stop building
normal cars and shift everything often
with government subsidies to this
electric stuff that many people don't
really want it's just going to happen
it's just happening okay
so you got to just get on board with it
I don't really care about people to
judge or the cars or what's going on in
the strike here
this story to me is about all of the
progressive Technic rat project
Progressive technocrats thrive on
de-politicizing human beings
what they thrive on is oh look it's
going to happen it's just going to
happen you have no say over it you have
no say over your own life you don't you
can do you can cry and you can whine and
you can vote and you can organize
politically but it doesn't matter it's
happening because progress demands it
progress with a capital P demands
my very very specific political program
that the Biden Administration is
spending a lot of money in power to
enforce is obviously not true if it were
true the Biden Administration wouldn't
need to mandate all this stuff
if it's just going to happen naturally
they wouldn't need to spend so much
political capital and and actual Capital
Money
to push this
it is
electric vehicles are spreading now
because of a particular government Focus
and because because that's what they
want and okay but maybe some of us don't
want that maybe some striking workers
don't want that maybe some ordinary
citizens don't want that and maybe we're
going to voice our opinion and even if
Pete bootage insists that history and
progress are the capital agent capital P
demand that we get rid of our gas
guzzling cars maybe we want to keep them
and so what what are we going to do then
well what the progressives do then what
the liberals do then is they say well
you don't have a right to say that
you don't have a right
and what we respond is well we this is
government of the People by the people
for the people what do you mean I can't
set my own environmental standards in my
own manufacturing standards they say no
no this is a liberal democracy
meaning
we're going to do liberalism and when
the Democracy goes along with that we're
going to celebrate when the Democracy
opposes liberalism we're going to tell
that democracy to shut up
it's a it's a constant process of
depolitization even beyond what Buddha
judge is talking about here you see this
in the constant pointing to science when
when the Liberals and the progressives
and the technocrats they say no the
science says that we have to do this
this and that it's not me it's not my
political desire it's not people
debating how to live together coming
from perhaps different first principles
and different trains of thought no no
it's just the science says that the
history sense that the textbook says
that the computer says that
the progress says that so you got to do
it and you lose your political rights
now speaking of depoliticizing this is
this is my favorite well have to refer
back to the debate for just one brief
second
the New York Times was fact-checking the
debate
and they fact checked a statement from
Vivek ramaswamy am I allowed to quote
Vivek from the debate on a certain
social media platform that doesn't like
when you say true things okay well I'll
just do it
the vague said
[Music]
everyone
is talking about convicting a murderer
and how it is completely blown up making
a murderous Narrative of Steven Avery
being falsely convicted for the murder
of Teresa albach there are already so
many people from around the country
commenting about how they've changed
their minds about Stephen Avery after
watching convicting a murderer take a
look at the series
coming up on convicting a murderer
biggest piece of evidence that viewers
to this day believe was planted it was a
story that was really tailor-made for
Hollywood he was on TV constantly saying
it's Manitowoc County they're framing me
there's got to be a setup because if I
didn't do it it had a plan to stop it
seemed like almost everyone believes
these filmmakers
his body language comes across as very
suspicious it looked like he was
caught and that is exactly what the
filmmakers LED you to believe why are
you editing my courtroom testimony you
should be still faithful to the facts I
started to realize more and more that
this was an entertainment business
this wasn't a piece of Journalism like I
thought it was going to be
[Music]
new episodes of convicting a murderer
are released every Thursday exclusively
on daily wire plus if you're not a
member head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe to sign up for access to this
groundbreaking series and the rest of
daily wires content my favorite comment
yesterday is from Dirk at work 33 who
says why is it that only Democrats hear
these racist dog whistles for a question
what is it what does it say about you if
you're the one who hears the dog
whistles hmm the biggest story of the
day I'm just getting to now
which is that a judge in New York
is ordered Trump's businesses
to completely shut down
they they tried to lock Trump up for
rape or something because if this
imagined this fantasy of this woman in
bird Goodman or whatever they tried to
lock him up for donating to his own
campaign in the Stormy Daniels case they
tried to lock him up for as president
calling the Georgia Secretary of State
and asking what was going on in the
election they tried to lock him up for
this that and everything else
insurrection
now they're they're trying to take away
all of his property
now this judge
ruled that Trump had inflated the value
of his properties and thereby gotten
sweetheart bank loans and he said this
constitutes fraud and so Trump's going
to have to forfeit all of his companies
which
completely insane just in general but
then when you zoom in on on what the
judge is even talking about you see that
the details are crazy too
this judge said that Mar-A-Lago this is
Trump's Palm Beach Resort
is worth 18 million dollars
Mar-A-Lago brings in 25 million dollars
a year
so the judge says that the the entire
Mar-A-Lago business is worth
significantly less than one year's
revenue from mar-a-laga
but then it gets even crazier because
that's not taking into account the real
estate which where Mar-A-Lago is
situated is some of the most expensive
real estate in the entire country in in
the world
Mar-A-Lago stretches from water to water
there's water on both sides of it
because it stretches across the entire
Island and it the island is extremely
valuable and it's in part one of the
most valuable parts of the island
if you look on Google Maps I was doing
this with temple last night
if you look at the tiny little property
just north of Mar-A-Lago
which obviously only has access to the
water on one side and it's much smaller
it's probably a quarter of the size
uh that that property was worth
between 50 and 100 million dollars okay
it's just completely so hold on you're
telling me so the the property that's
very tiny in north and not nearly as
built up and not nearly as cool and
storied and the the buildings are not as
nice you telling me that is worth
double more than double what Mar-A-Lago
is worth
it's nuts Mar-A-Lago is probably worth
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars one one expert
put the value of Mar-A-Lago at over one
billion dollars which is reasonable
actually that's not out of the realm of
possibility Trump's own estimate of the
market value is uh 612 million dollars
which I think is
perhaps even conservative
so it doesn't make sense but we got to
stop trying to make this make sense
we got to stop
they want to get him in in the olden
days when a political leader was a
threat to another political faction
that political leader would be
ostracized would be physically removed
he could be assassinated would be sent
to a prison Island somewhere would be
kicked out of the polity for 10 years
and they would just get rid of them
now we don't do that because we pretend
that we live in this totally normal
neutral political order where it's all
fine but that's not what this is about
none of these cases are about Trump
raping a woman in Bergdorf Goodman's
that obviously never happened none of
these cases are about Trump paying off
Stormy Daniels and making any kind
campaign contribution to his own
Campaign which he's allowed to do none
of these cases are about a president of
the United States calling the secretary
of state of Georgia none of these none
of it is about any of that
Mar-A-Lago being worth fifty dollars but
none of this about Mar-A-Lago being
worth less than some apartments in New
York City
this is about getting Trump and it will
never stop
it will never ever stop he is literally
Hitler and they will stop at nothing to
to prevent him from being president
again this is an argument both for and
against Trump in 2024. the people who
prefer other candidates in 2024 are
saying this the GOP is suicidal by
picking Trump because the Democrats will
never let him win again they'll lock him
up they'll kill him they'll rig the vote
they'll just they won't let him win
and the pro-trump people are saying
yeah because he's right over the Target
because he's obviously a threat to the
Democrat political order in a way that
previous Republican presidents and
presidential candidates have not been
and furthermore are we just going to let
the Democrats now pick our candidates
because they say no that one's
unacceptable so you can't have them so
we're gonna say okay fine yeah they
might lock him up they might take his
property so no sorry it's it's a it's a
it's an argument from both sides
or for both sides but all of this still
redounds to my point I who I guess I'm
the last conservative in America who
really likes Donald Trump and really
likes Rhonda Santos and likes vivekan
likes a lot of these other candidates
and I'm not endorsing in the primary
but my observation from that is
regardless if you love him or hate him
Trump is sui generis Trump is unique he
is an American original there's no
comparison there's nobody like him today
there's probably been nobody like him in
American history and so if you're trying
to
if you're trying to impose him on the
ordinary rules of politics it ain't
gonna work okay today is
theology Thursday
I have a whole plan for theology
Thursday given to me by Professor Jacob
who's sitting right across from that
camera wearing a wife beater where
looking like you know Fredo Corleone
over here maybe Sonny Corleone the show
continues now you don't want to miss
this become a member use code Knowles
Canada wlas at checkout for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
good